foreign
[Music]
you will be placed in a facility with
other violent juvenile offenders they
could learn from their mistakes by
thinking on their sins
welcome to Incarnate Lord
you suffer great pain in your young life
Jackie's gonna come for us again
bless me Father for I have sinned it's
been three days since my last confession
um yes right
we don't know how many chunkies are out
there
great another color doll with a shady
plant
s
how many of you are there
wait you got a knife yeah I got a knife
they passed them out at orientation
don't make me come back there
I was gonna take over the world but
weren't for that [ __ ] from hell
when Glenda it's so nice to see your
sweet faces mom who the hell is Nica
Pierce
your mother is a psychotic murderer who
thinks she's in love with me and she
chopped off on my lips and she kept me
trapped in here for a year mom's a
murderer I'm so lesbian
there is an evil in our Miss and we must
confront it
I'm the MVP of Serial murder
I mean I I killed more people than you
have insta followers
never stop fighting
oh Jesus died Chucky
I am risen
didn't even take me three days
[Music]